I haven't heard from Tyler for a bit but
I did receive this very concerning video
it's wild out here I'm gonna find him
I'm gonna find Nessie I'm gonna find
Mothman I'm gonna find Bigfoot I don't
need them
and as concerning as that video was I
then received an even more concerning
video Tyler what are we doing
Mothman no not that you think he likes
Baja Blast
Bob
[Laughter]
I don't exactly know what Tyler's up to
right now
um and I don't want to think about it
too hard but he hasn't been responding
to my text so either he's having fun or
he's having
anyway if you're gonna go Cryptid
hunting why not do it in cloak's new
Cryptid Hunters gear available through
the link in the description below go to
cloakbrand.com right now and check it
out
and always remember Cryptids aren't real
Tyler
welcome to the mystery flesh pit
National Park come Wonder at the vistas
of meat and Madness stare deep into the
pits of Flesh and uh whatever the hell
that is yes it's time to explore the
bronchial Forest feel the great yearly
exhalation cycle of the Permian Basin
super organism
during exhalation excessive carbon
dioxide concentration excessive heat and
aggressive behavioral patterns of local
Wildlife create potentially dangerous
conditions to cast and park Personnel
but don't mind that it's fun for the
whole family if you go into the mystery
flat pit you're only gonna have a great
time look at these guys and gals they're
having a great time also you can go you
can bone in the amniotic thermal Springs
uh don't go to the libido bath unless
you want some libido so the reason I'm
giving you an overview of the mystery
flesh pit is because I have a game here
called living Abyss
so living Abyss is wow that's all I get
so living Abyss wow
hello living Abyss is a game about the
mystery flesh pit uh I actually have
been following the mystery flesh bit for
a while just because it's a very
weird the images that I I showed you are
basically where it comes from there's no
book it's just a website or it's
actually just a Tumblr I think that
showcases a lot of um in-universe things
that
well okay
basically it's all built up from World
building I think I I think the first
post actually was about World building I
think I've talked about it once before
but that was about it
other than that it's um it's fun for the
whole family and it's a national park
where everyone can go and dive deep into
the pits and when I say you might be
thinking like oh miss reflected what
does that mean it means exactly what you
think it means
it's a pit of Flesh
that's a mystery it's a super organism
that goes down and down there's probably
like a diagram of like the mystery flesh
pit iceberg that just keeps going down
into the horribleness
and it goes into the horribleness
it really goes what is that a cigarette
what is that
Is that ah is that a sperm I don't like
that
well at least there are lights down here
so I fell
um but it's okay this thing uh
[Music]
are you trying to intimidate me I think
you'll find I'm unintimid dateable hey
hi ow
okay well that was a that was dumb
I don't even know if I'm going the right
way I don't even know if there is a
right way to go but there's lights here
so I'm on one of the trails and yes
there are Trails down here
because it's a national park that you
can explore
maintained by the National Park Service
because that's the thing what is that
who what is that
what is that
oh no
uh hello
that looks man-made can you help me
there seems to be something following me
oh God no oh
all right so there's these things called
um like macro bacteria and um
fauna there's things alive down here and
you don't want to talk to them they sure
do want to talk to you though what if I
go this way
I don't think there's actually going to
be any getting out of here
hmm
well that doesn't look good and by not
good I mean it looks like everything
else here but
still that's not very good
um all jokes aside uh one of the things
I find Most Fascinating about the
mystery flesh pit is just how normal it
is in Universe just how casually people
treat it and yet how cosmically horrible
it is it is probably one of the best
examples I've seen of just Cosmic horror
just like the fact that you can't even
understand it so everyone just was like
ah it's fine it's fine because this
actually is one big living thing we're
just the tiny little bacteria crawling
around it and that's what this game is
just exploring in this wonderful world
of meat and Madness so this must be
something for like either a code or some
kind of a key card system because I
think that was a slightly different
color than the one I saw before
there's got to be something else there
a good thing I got my flashlight because
without it I wouldn't be able to see a
thing
oh
okay so those things are gonna chase me
until they kill me
but there's something over there
okay what is that thing is that a key
card
could that be a key card
key card important
open open open
wait no this is useless
oh hi is there anything else here is
that another path
oh God
okay
it might be an endless Chasm or it might
be a dead end I don't know how much good
this is gonna do me because the last
time I got caught by one of those things
I didn't exactly have um
an injury to repair
oh this is a path oh
what are you
hi
uh phone
right there's emergency phones down here
what is going on there
why did that happen
did I use the med kit or something
found
at five
oh
I saved
good
great
battery you told me I could be down here
and I can run out of battery because
that's a problem
what is
what is my flashlight working
what do you mean why is my flashlight
not working I just put a new battery in
it didn't I oh battery ah
oh
all right well we're not going that way
um there's another path back there if I
hit a dead end over here I'll come back
but there seems to be a
a dragon in the way of that pretty sure
that's what that was I'm dying I'm dying
I'm dying why am I dying all right so
don't go into the there there's some big
bug or a dragon what are you
I don't like you
what are you I'm gonna sneak by I don't
have any stamina oh what is going on
with it is it that is head or it's ass
I can't tell it's moving at one frame a
minute
I guess we're good
so what you're probably Hearing in the
distance the rumbling is what's known as
tectonic carnal moans
I will not explain anything further well
I can already detect a problem of me
being in this place I don't know where I
am
and I don't know where I've been and I
don't know where I'm going what is that
ah right okay so don't go that way it's
bad
good to know
but I don't know if there's something
that I need to get to be able to go
through there or if I just have to suck
it up and go because I don't think going
down is gonna get me out of here I'm
pretty sure I need to go up okay this
small box is over there that's nice
I'm almost out of battery so they better
give me another one soon
oh
that's good I don't remember seeing
anything with yellow on it but then
again I don't remember a lot of things
hello
battery that's probably good
battery that's also good
okay
well that's great
um what's that over there please tell me
this goes around directly to that oh
I've never mind I'm I'm an idiot use
like
all right well how is this going to do
anything for me oh wow that's quick on
that
that's pretty quick
okay
I don't think I see anything in the
distance
oh my God
oh
okay I don't I don't know anything about
that I I don't know I don't know a thing
about that
I don't know what that's supposed to be
okay but I'm gonna leave now uh Alexian
give them some more fun informational
Graphics from the uh from the uh
from the mystery Flash Pad blog put some
like nice um 19 or a mid-1900s
informational video like from the 1950s
from America I know you're Portuguese
but
in America we taught our kids stuff
through TV
not not when I was a kid this was way no
it don't matter just go straight okay go
step right into the enigmatic wonders of
mystery fresh pit National Park nestled
charmingly in the heart of Junction
Texas come on over and be one of the
many to explore and enjoy this wonderful
place unwind and rejuvenate at our
exclusive yo Spa go for a stroll on our
many enchanting Trails or for the
bravest Souls dare to venture Into the
Heart of the pit where a harmonious
ecosystem of wildlife awaits your
Discovery in case of enforcing incidents
make sure to use one of our many
emergency call boxes stationed
throughout the park we might not answer
though which in that case you're
completely on your own
[Applause]
National Park where the mystery is yours
to find
[Music]
I don't know where I'm going I think I
might be backtracking but I'm not sure
everything does look the same but my
sense of direction is kind of like uh
you might have done this before which I
suppose would be fine because it all
seemed to go multiple different
directions
um
okay yeah I think I did go oh man is
that the jumpy weird one sometimes if
you I don't know if you guys can see the
darkness
but there might be paths spitting off on
the side here because there were on
those other places so maybe there's
something that I couldn't originally see
there is is that there is okay there is
God it's dark
and I only have one more battery so they
better give me something soon okay so I
definitely haven't gone this what is
that why does it look like a skull what
is happening
light is playing tricks on me are those
creatures is that thing still falling I
can't see anything give me a battery
there we go uh use
okay
well that's good
um is that thing still follow me also
what was that what is that what is it
what is that supposed to be
is that a macro bacteria
nothing
first aid kit I don't need any of that
don't don't even think about it
don't I gotta go oh that's I can't get
up there
uh oh
um uh see I don't remember there being
anything like that in any of the
archives that's just weird that is
something I've I don't know what that is
and I don't like it
Slenderman ass oh it's like a drop down
no
oh it just keeps going
and I don't know where it goes I don't
know where I'm supposed to go
I got a yellow key card and that's it
I'm climbing up but I mean is this
actually gonna get me out of here I just
got oh there it is okay well I better
not hit a dead end because um
that thing ain't slowing down
but this is up I like up oh it's another
phone better give me more batteries
because I'm in trouble
a first aid kit I don't need that
has a battery oh but I'm assuming that
was me using that
five
saved
all right dope dope
nope
I gotta stop oh no
oh what are you doing oh
oh
so you just run away if I shine a
flashlight on you wish I'd have known
that sooner but also if I didn't hear it
approaching which I don't think it made
a sound because everything is weirdly
quiet in this game I'm thinking I might
not have noticed it and then I just
would have died just um
stick figure
I don't know
[Music]
can't pick it up
got this and use it I guess nothing in
there
okay oh great that's helpful oh boy
oh what
okay whatever it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter I'm just gonna keep going
I seem to be going up I like up maybe
that's what it was like down like the
gas was just me it indicating you're
going the wrong way you need to go up
idiot
okay well that goes down
now technically I did go on one of these
paths when I was trying to when I
realized I was looping back I'm just
hoping that the geometry is the same and
it's not necessarily that I somehow loop
back because I swear I was going up you
guys saw this is an incline up this is
an upbeat this is this is uppie
there is no no
[Music]
how how
I was upbeat the whole time
I was so happy I was like climbing the
mountain
how also how have I not seen
a single author of the various
um oh well I shouldn't be going
oh
that's a door if that is to a key card
then I don't have the purple one
why best to go this way
all right
damn it does get dimmer over time that's
great I love batteries like that
safe point out
point out a big room
few boxes strewn about
no one's following me I think there's
something over there
I don't I don't need this
why do you keep giving me this I don't
know how often they think I'm getting
injured but I
how do I get rid of this can I drop
something
oh good thank you please
I don't need to know about the wildlife
I'm not here to learn anymore
I'm here to go home
saved good don't mind me
that's a battery good
that's nothing good okay
oh oh
ah well this looks official
it's following me good
please tell me that you need a yellow
key card really banking on the yellow
one
this looks so super official
this looks amazing could I just knock on
the door and they would open it
yes
no damn it Half-Life has door God damn
it do I need a white key card or
something and if I don't have a battery
by the time that dude's charging at me
am I going to be just dead
probably
there oh is that the dragon I don't even
know what you're supposed to be I don't
want to know oh what are you
what are you
oh what is wrong with you
why do you exist
man the carnal moans are really kicking
up
I need another battery please blue
I know our blue is garsh oh my God what
is that
what are you
okay
I swear if this Loops me back to
somewhere I bet
oh yeah you better get out of here
whatever you are whoever you are run run
so I haven't been here before but I
don't feel any better about that I'm
gonna need a battery because I'm
official yes
I'm alive for another day is it
somewhere I've been
there's a news these boxes open
is that open I think it might be open
it's open okay let me go back the way I
came and I'm gonna try to chase down no
because that would have been a big
circles because if I came back out here
then it all would have connected anyway
so then it wouldn't matter if I go the
way that that stick figure man went it
would still be the wrong way because I
would just loop back to that door so I
think this path because I think I came
through like one of those and I think
this is another way to go
unless this is the way I went to get to
the thing but I don't know trying to get
me to remember anything at this depth
and this level of meat is going to be
impossible
I gotta start conserving my battery
because there's really no difference
between like
full brightness
and half battery
oh God it's the beginning again okay
there's the purple door again which is
incredibly unhelpful this isn't gonna
help me because I'm just gonna go back
the way I did before I should have I
should have known I did backtrack when I
came through there everything just kind
of spins off into eternity unless this
is the other this is a big honking room
that's where the door is well then how
did I get here for no that's where those
things are I am so confused
confused oh it's
hi dude
hey dude
dude yeah you better run
are you really sneaking
I don't like that it's got to be a path
over on that far side of the room
it can't all just be this because that
room that I was in before that I thought
I'd been before was this one I thought
it was this one but it wasn't
so is there a path over here
anywhere over here yes there is that's
the stairs so let me go through that far
cave over there
I think that's just where the dude came
through when he ran away from me oh my
God
go away that dude yeah I think that's
where that dude came from I don't know
why but it's so weird to see a humanoid
figure just being down here you expect
monsters right you expect freaks of
nature you expect big old macro bacteria
you do not expect another weird skeletal
person it's like that dude the the
zombies from like Ocarina of Time you
know the ones that just mentally scarred
everyone if the big door was a white key
card then it's got to be a chaining
thing there might have been a blue key
card or door down here and then that
probably leads to like a purple card and
I bet the white card is in the purple
card gate and I think I saw some other
gate down there it might have been blue
if it's white I'm just gonna be
incredibly confused and I don't think
anything's right oh it's that dragon
it's a weird ass Dragon but there's a
save over there so I can't go down those
because that's just death and I think
these paths just cross over to each
other
so it's like some kind of lateral
movement across these is all about the
same wait but where did I come in is
that a path okay but this was I think
this is like the first save I ever came
across
cause then I saw the dragon and I was
very upset
it's not good for my psyche
my emotional state was incredibly
compromised in that moment but I am
getting a vague sense and understanding
of my location which is going to assist
me greatly in finding a place to go [__]
myself because I am lost I think I see
the dude pretty sure that's the dude but
then where okay there's a box there I
remember opening that but where was the
path that led to I saw another gate I
saw two gates I saw two gates somewhere
but I'm lost and I can't find any gate
none gate man I hope I don't ever
actually get lost in some place that
requires me to think clearly and
actually concentrate because I'll just
be screaming at the walls and in this
particular circumstance screaming at the
walls is a bad idea because the walls
are alive
please tell me he's not a whoa what was
that sound
bro
[Applause]
all right all right I'm mature okay open
ah what is that
gas mask
wow gas mask okay so do I not need the
blue anymore I'm gonna guess that I
don't and then I can have a gas mask
whoa how long does it last
can I go down in the gas now Okay so
I can only have one
it seems so that means it probably
doesn't expire
right is there any other negative
repercussions for having this I can't
see my Sprint meter but I'm assuming
I've got the general feel of it okay
all right so I can go down in the gas
right that's what this means and boy
howdy was that a lot of backtracking to
be able to get that and go over here
let's see an um queue up
jump scare like 17 the one in your
collection
um and put it put a timer on for like
three minutes and then when three
minutes is up the set the jump scare to
blast really loud right then and there
uh people will forget about it so don't
worry about it cool thank you thank you
you're gonna forget oh God I sure hope
someone isn't sneaking up on me
flashlight's okay Sprint bar is okay I
seem to be doing okay shockingly
save good
oh oh
okay but I got the gas mask on so
whatever's down here I'm assuming is
going to be valuable for me whether it's
like the purple key and I need I because
I still have a yellow key card I just
need to you know
get it okay gas mask is on nobody is
following
all right new area unlocked
I know it's probably annoying to deal
with the flashlight going on and off
like that oh I hope that this is gonna
be fine I got the gas mask I can only
assume
but I just gotta conserve battery
because I don't have anything else
man it's a different type of darkness
when it's pure green
good this must connect up to all the
other gas tunnels and I'm thinking that
because this is just a big macro
organism I'm swimming in fart I'm pretty
sure this is just 100 pure fart so it
wouldn't really kill me but it's really
a death is preferable I think that's
what we're dealing with here I really
hope that dude isn't coming after me
because I am not I can't see dick I mean
I really hope I don't see dick down here
I don't need macro dick in my life
that's a sentence I never thought I'd
say
well here I am
whoa whoa what just happened whoa whoa
why what is that what happened what is
going on
what is that
oh what's that what's happening
am I being digested
am I being digested do I need this oh
don't put don't do that
uh okay no battery no first aid because
I don't need it too tough
I don't know why that's happening
but uh
what's going on there on there what's
that no
[Music]
no what was even the point of first aid
kid if that yeah
what are you looking at what are you
looking at huh
you're not scary you're cute oh no
you're cute okay well that didn't make a
lot of sense what happened I'm gonna try
one of the other ones but if it's just
death down at the bottom there then I'm
not even gonna this it would take me an
hour to go down get that go up to the
purple gate get out of here who take me
so long but I guess if I was really in
this situation would I just curl up and
give up would I just roll over and die
no I'm so strong
oh did the jump scare happen cool that's
awesome I don't know what's with the
torpedo thing torpedo monster really was
inconvenient it was just so fast there's
nothing I could have done and it's like
yeah why do you give uh a first aid kit
if it's just pure death
pure 100
organic death okay that's a path that
broad connects back to the other one
that probably connects back to the other
one
which means that Dead Ahead there's got
to be something good for me can't see
[__] too much fart but I'm still smiling
something about one of you
what is you what is that well that's
just death well that's just death okay
that's death avoid the death don't go
the death way I'll go left to then
what's this mirror did that monster look
like a flaccid penis
anyone else just me is this death
these death is
death ooze it is death what do you want
from me whoa I'm getting too close to
you guys can that dude follow me down
here is he immune to this those things
seem to be living okay God it is just
you can't see nothing
it's not like they're giving me
batteries down here
I can't even get near that if there was
batteries in there I couldn't get them
and who knows maybe something in there
is like a key card that I need maybe
that's what I need and I wouldn't be
able to get close because you got death
dudes
well what are you supposed to do what
are you doing
it's like as soon as they spot you
you're danzo
I'm gonna go down the other tunnel
there's got to be like one more Beyond
this one you know what I mean
there's got to be one more Beyond it
because if there is one more Beyond then
that's really cool I wonder if this mask
is like the mask in SCP Containment
Breach after you upgrade it it just like
lets you run forever nope
definitely not do I have two masks did I
get two masks oh is that why I couldn't
pick it up anything I picked up two oops
well that's part of the problem
all right these unopened I definitely
opened these before
definitely did they're probably just
empty probably because I died they just
reclosed them but I doubt there's
anything in them nope yeah no batteries
for me I definitely wasted a lot of the
batteries I'm gonna say that straight up
there were probably plenty of batteries
for me to go around and I didn't even
think about rationing them because I
thought how how long could I be down
here uh
I'm fine I'm 100 good and yeah little
did I know oh wait
I'm dead Okay this looks like that place
I just was okay
so this seems near and dear to where I
was because I I definitely see
penis monsters
and if I could ooh this is dicey
oh I know oh which way you going bud
you don't see me do you you don't see me
you don't see me okay
battery oh okay all right there's
nowhere okay there's nothing you can do
how could you do anything how about that
you can't you can't not maybe it's one
of those things that it only notices
when you run because otherwise how would
you get away from it okay so it's got to
be something like that like you turn
your sort of like a crap
there's a Crouch that's got to be it
that must be right because otherwise
what else would you do maybe that was a
fundamental part of this game maybe it's
a mechanic that I just didn't know about
maybe it was something uh essential and
I am too dumb to realize until now it is
I'm crouched
I don't know where it is but
I'm sure that it's around I guess it
just so happened to not be in this one
spot
it's gone it it's just gone or is it
over is that it over there ah that might
be it well either way I have a chance
here so I'm gonna take it well not that
oh I see right it's doing that thing and
also I need to throw that down
okay I'm crouched this is gonna be the
ultimate test because I think it would
be close enough to kill me but I think
I'm moving in the right direction
oh my God I think I am
okay
ah that would have killed me if the
light got there but I think that proves
that crouching does make it so you can
go and maybe it's blind to light so
maybe that's also a good thing I did it
uh maybe I don't know I I figured it out
good I think so I should be able to get
up now
and go
apparently I can okay so running real
bad oh
another one of those things oh boy
well I apparently picked the dumb way oh
man crouching is so slow I'm gonna run
into the thing you gonna kill me you
might as well no you're just coming over
this way great
oh boy
well I haven't gone into anything of
value so
this was still the wrong way to go oh
good well
oh my God oh my God
oh my God
what what am I alive what's going on
you're a fly man
why are you there what is it happening
what okay so this
can this just not see me if I'm crouched
because I was crouched moving and I was
very near it so I I'm guessing crouching
just renders me
safe
even light doesn't bother it it's just
walking and or running understood
understood that would explain why they
would come after me as soon as I would
run for the boxes
wow it just really wants to walk right
by me so
that's cute that's cute also holy crap
what happened with that dude I don't
know but I got lucky I think
I think he might have bugged or
something well I mean it was a bug but
you know different all right so this
should just lead back to where those
boxes are I see lights up there but I'm
thinking it's got to be those boxes over
there
if I had managed to get both of them
open they might have had a key card or
at least I hope so if they don't have a
key card then I don't know what it wants
me to do I don't know what I'm supposed
to do here it don't make no sense so I'm
just gonna approach from this side and
hope for the best
these boxes do have lights on them I
don't know if that's pertinent or
anything
kid well that was pointless wow so glad
great cool I don't even think there's a
way over here oh good just peachy
just peachy I'm running you can't stop
me from running
man that
that is annoying I think it's just back
out right
yeah this is just a poop air
is this the delineation line of the poop
Air Zone I thought I saw a Pearson
so I'm just all of that to go into the
poop air and get nothing
was there anything else was there any
other way down there there has to be
something down there there is not
nothing down there there is definitely
something down there and I'm gonna find
it I have not come this far to give up
now there's no more poop zones I don't
think so it's gotta be something down
there so if I go down the middle one I
believe there's a path to the left and
if that just bonds up back with the
other place imma be real pissed because
I didn't see that in the other place
but whatever
oh
this was here ah okay I don't have that
do I
you better be yellow
God
damn it
where is Green
Oh no no what's the point of yellow
I tried
I tried to escape the mystery flesh bit
but the thing is
once you go in
[Music]
you're probably not coming back out
and that's a story that I think we can
all relate to so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down in the comments below uh if
you want to play this for yourself and
finish it
link is in the description thank you
and as always I will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]